[Music]
you've seen her blow up on Tick Tock pop
up and flash mobs and give talk show
hosts a nervous breakdown
Now Catch Megan in her big screen debut
that proves the only success that means
anything in Hollywood these days is
starting a viral dance craze
foreign
[Music]
was missing
number three gun get ready for Megan the
newest toy Sensation from funky she's
dressed like Teddy Ruxpin the Sephora
she's programmed to Meg's brain experts
say the preferred method is to give your
child the choice it's called The
Division and she's generally an
off-putting little creep that no child
would feel safe sleeping next to
oh Jesus Christ after getting her salad
tossed on girls Allison Williams is back
and this nepo baby has a message for the
haters life isn't fair and it's not fun
to root for her I'm into this with a big
big head start and I feel like it's
totally okay to admit that huh that's a
pretty honest take actually she's she's
playing Gemma a woman who's really more
of a Karen have you seen this dog it is
a monster I'm chasing it off with my
property every other day this girl boss
will try anything to avoid parenting her
orphan knees except her a Humanity like
a normal rich white lady but gemma's got
her hands full as spunky's Hotshot toy
designer slash lead programmer slash
robotics engineer slash marketing
department she's more than just a toy
she's part of the family it was good
slash girl who builds fighting bags for
fun see that gen Z you have to work at
being a psycho
and we spent a hundred thousand dollars
want to generate sympathy for a kid fast
but don't know how to write try killing
other parents in a car crash
[Applause]
I know that road
like with gemma's niece Katie because I
guess being careless with deadly
machines runs in her family we should
have put chains on the car
together Katie Gemma and Megan will play
a Wicked Game of who's the mommy Megan
turn off are you sure until it finally
erupts in an extremely mild third act
Rampage packed with fewer on-screen
kills than a Dragon Ball Z dub
because the most hard-hitting Cuts in
this horror movie were the ones they
made to make it PG-13 oh good every main
character lived see you in myforgan
so leave the kids at home with an iPad
and enjoy a 90-minute finger wag at
parents who leave their kids at home
with an iPad and what's basically the
fourth Pinocchio movie to come out in
the last 12 months
with a little bit to say about
technology a little bit to say about
capitalism and one very big thing they
want to say about parenting it's better
to let the Terminator raise your kid
than to even think about sending them to
Florida
Pokemon
Elon brosk Katie ratio death lab for qde
shrieks and Geeks Real Steel anyone
remember Real Steel and the boss baby
and get me a kombucha
shut up Meg
so Jim is definitely going to prison for
life right
who loves orange soda Cal loves orange
soda is it true I do I do I do
what did the hermit crab say to the
other hermit crab before they fought one
shall stand one shall fall